Jacob Peralta is my best detective he
likes putting away bad guys and he loves
solving puzzles the only puzzle he
hasn't saw
the next time I see you I'd like you to
be wearing a necktie oh actually the
last Captain didn't care if we wore ties
well your new captain does and more
importantly he cares that you follow his
direct orders at the pawn shops and
canvas the neighborhood and while you're
out you can buy yourself a tie oh
actually sir
I'm wearing a tie right now check it out
secret tie first of all I think you're
kind of overdoing it with the manscaping
but more importantly detective why do
you refuse to take my order seriously
does anyone here know why it's so
important to me that you all dress
appropriately
for highly trained detectives and not
one of you can solve this simple mystery
okay I want to be briefed on any new
developments any questions I was going
to ask you if you thought I was doing
too much manscaping but we solved that
one so I'm good
that's fine work detective thank you
very much sir
Testament to what can be achieved when
you dress appropriately
let's pound it out
well you're a poor police officer if you
don't think that people can surprise you
not these people here watch this I know
what everyone's going to do tonight it's
Thursday so Gina's going to leave early
to rehearse with her new dance group
Dancy Reagan they're the first ladies of
movement Amy's going to be going over
her weekly budget and Charles will be
attending a pizza for one cooking class
tonight's menu pepper alone and if I run
and leap it Terry he will most certainly
catch me in his arms coming in no
holding coffee
Ready or Not Here Comes My Hellhound
[Music]
I'm a mob
the flat top has left the big top uh
wait where's shake well there's a TV
card suspiciously in the middle of the
room that ceiling tile is out of place
and he said he was going to hide
somewhere Reckless so I'm guessing he's
up there that's right Amy I'm in the
ceiling unlike you boring old fogies I
found the craziest
don't worry
my bones and ribs broke my phone hey
Boyle no you haven't had Peralta as a
secondary in a while be careful it could
be rough hey Saboteur that's not true I
happen to be a very good secondary
so you were just borrowing those cars
ask about his bank account ask about his
bank account ask him about it
account
you should ask him about his bank
account Captain Santiago broke the glass
you can't give up control you're
terrible at taking your primary's orders
you just do whatever you want I could go
on and on and on it's something no lover
of yours has ever said blammo look I can
be an amazing secondary and I'll prove
it I know you will jig in the Box I
don't ever call me that again I'm
driving we should leave now carry my bag
so talk to me Goose how we looking sexy
but not like we're trying too hard like
sure we're trying but it's almost
effortless yeah no I knew all of that I
meant the money thing oh my first
impression is that you have a
debilitating spending problem Jake you
have six massage chairs well they don't
make a massage couch okay but you also
have three turntables oh yeah I'm
learning how to spin check it out
all I have are my Grandma's old klezmer
records and I still haven't quite
figured out how to sync up the Beats but
it's not bad right it's awful it sounds
like Joy they are falling down some
stairs this is so unfair I've lived in
this building 15 years and then all of a
sudden they decide they're going co-op
with zero warning it seems illegal they
didn't tell you this was happening well
it's possible I missed a letter but I
doubt it
check the mail tab mail tub nope no no
see it's impossible to find anything in
here it's not my fault this is actually
a cool little bathroom nice clawfit tub
which I will never throw my mail into
again Gina I know you like champagne
with a drop of pomegranate juice I like
to say it's a Nature's classiest alcohol
mixed with its narcious fruit
and Peralta I hope this will do it's a
can of orange soda from when some other
children visited it's perfect thank you
for inviting us in yes I invited Gina in
you were with her okay you know Kevin
maybe if we if we're out what caused
Raymond's bad mood we could fix it great
idea do you know I suppose we could look
into it yes great let's go right now no
time to lose don't look just run you're
trying to get me out of here before I
see the orange soda you spilled in the
chair aren't you I'm already out the
door it worked I can't believe that
waxing the floor that we're all stuck in
here I've never seen him do this before
they do it once a month we just never
been on the night shift I know it's like
we're being punished we are for going to
Florida ah
I don't listen to so much stuff you all
say well frankly I pitied a lot of you
you look out there and see a problem I
look out there and see an opportunity
I'm gonna slide on that slippery floor
all the way from Holt's office to the
elevator you're gonna do the fbp that's
right Rosa I'm doing the full bullpen
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
standing
standing forever
[Music]
[Music]
the full Bullpen here are three cases
with sloppy paperwork here are two
pictures
one is your locker the other is a
garbage dump in the Philippines can you
tell which is which
that one sit down they're both your
locker I should have guessed that it's
good this folder is labeled undies comma
dirty so I won't confuse it with undies
comic clean also who cares about all
these rules I have more felony arrests
than any other detective here you also
have more mice living in your desk than
any other Detective
Algernon
you guys algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together now
he's grumpy
this neighborhood's amazing class just
seeps out of every vestibule keep it in
your pants Santiago
Skelly I specifically said no shorts
charges not my fault you said so many
things about shorts I got confused man
did I screw the pooch oh Peralta Where
Have You Been sorry I'm sorry I know I
am 35 minutes late yikes but I had to
stop and get some wine hello good sir
I'd like your finest bottle of wine
please that will be sixteen hundred
dollars great I'd like your eight
dollars bottle of wine please gotta say
I'm loving these I always wanted to wear
Hammer pants stop Hammer Time no stop
joking around you're wearing those pants
to keep your testicles away from your
body's warm core so your sperm don't
overheat well I am loving the breeze I
feel like I'm 83. all right Focus up
this is our pregnancy war room on the
master calendar we will track ovulation
Windows menstruation cycles and every
uterine deposit uterine deposit is that
what we're calling sex now it seems a
little clinical well you could always
shorten it to UD or
UD yeah I don't want to do that here's a
list of everything you cannot eat while
we're trying to conceive no more nachos
even even if they're in a novelty
baseball helmet no whoa this is serious
who adhere to a strict exercise regimen
and sleep schedule also no more video
games because they cause stress and they
raise your heart rate more stress than
being a police officer Jake I've seen
you play Mario Party Mario cheats